Welcome everyone,
we'll get started in just a minute.
All right,
welcome to leadership of the society.
In this season we're talking
about reimaging work post-COVID.
And I'm excited to have three guests today
to talk about shifting demographics in
the workplace.
So, I our three guests
are Laura Carstensen,
professor of psychology
at Stanford University.
Also the founding director of
the Stanford Center on Longevity, and
the author of A Long Bright Future,
Happiness, Health, and
Financial Security in an Age
of Increased Longevity.
We also have Manu Meel.
Manu serves the CEO of BridgeUSA,
a national organization that's
investing in the future of democracy.
And Jennifer Liu, and Jennifer Liu is
a workplace reporter for CNBC Make It.
Where she writes about
the culture of work and
she also contributes to
Make It'd Millennial Money franchise,
a series that details how people earn,
spend, and save their money.
Thank you all for
agreeing to be with me here today.
>> Thanks for having us.
>> Great, so,
let me start off by just recommending
something that we've all heard a lot
about recently.
So the workforce is aging.
So according to the US, I mean,
according to on the National Council
on Compensation Insurance,
we can talk about why
they're doing these studies.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> The US labor force aged 65 and
older is expected to grow by more
than 50% in the next ten years,
making it 10% of the total labor force.
So the workers aged 65 and older are
predicted to be more than 10% of the total
labor force in the next ten years.
What challenges and opportunities do you
see tied to the aging of the workforce?
And Laura,
I'd love to hear from you first.
>> Sure, I think we hear a lot
about the aging of the workforce.
I think the bigger story embedded
in this is the age
diversification of the workforce.
So this is the first time in human
history where we have had five and
six birth cohorts working together in
the same workforce at the same time.
We've just never had this before.
So, when we talk about aging workforce, it
kind of focuses us on those 65 and older.
But really the issue is how do people
from very different backgrounds,
very different ages, work together in
a way that optimizes that diversity?
>> Great, and
what other opportunities there?
I'm curious how you think about that.
>> The opportunities
are enormous in my view.
We don't have a lot of research yet
on mixed-age workforces,
but the studies that are here now suggest
that productivity may well go up.
So there's a famous study that was done
in an automobile manufacturing plant
in Europe where they compared productivity
on an assembly line of work teams
that were all young, work teams that
were old, and mixed-age work teams.
And what they found is that the mixed-age
work teams were most productive of all.
The young teams were really fast,
and they made a lot of mistakes.
And the older teams were slower, but
they essentially didn't make mistakes.
And the other piece of this from other
studies is that when young people make
mistakes in manufacturing and
selling, they're very expensive.
[LAUGH] When older people make mistakes,
they're not as expensive.
So to me the opportunity is
you put the ages together and
you have teams of people where
you have experienced workers,
who have lots of knowledge about that
field and their particular tasks.
And you mix them in with young
people who are ambitious and
fast learners and active, and
you see really great outcomes.
So, we've seen this kind of
increase in productivity now,
not just in assembly line workers,
but in lots of different contexts.
And I think that's the possibility.
But the trick is what is that mix?
What's the optimal mix?
How do you do it?
How do you put people together?
And how do you make sure everybody's
got a voice in those teams?
>> Yes, what I hear a lot about lately
is the tension between older workers and
younger workers.
And I'm curious, Jennifer, you write
in this space of the culture of work.
What do you see in terms of the tensions
between younger and older workers?
>> Yeah, that's a great question.
Earlier this year, my team and
I at CNBC Make It did a big
series around middle-aged millennials.
When you think of millennials
in the workplace,
you might still think of young
professionals, recent grads.
When in fact some of the oldest
millennials are turning 40 this year.
And when you think of reaching 40,
these workers are reaching or
still working towards some
major life milestones,
starting a family, buying a home,
paying off student loans.
And all of that translates to
what they bring to the workplace.
The stereotype that millennials are young,
and hungry,
and ready to job hop to find
the next best opportunity.
While that is true of all younger workers,
people who are in this kind of
middle-age reaching middle management
track are feeling these intense,
personal pressures.
And that impacts the decisions that they
make in their careers as far as going for
promotions, finding
opportunities to advance.
There has been a decades long
disinvestment in learning and
development programs in corporate America.
So the moving from employer to employer,
of course, leads to attrition.
And establishing that
company loyalty is not maybe
necessarily at the top of
these professionals' minds.
And of course, that can breed some
tension between people who are Younger,
working toward establishing
themselves in their career have
put in at this point a decade plus
of their lives into their work.
But are still having trouble
reaching levels of management or
leadership, where they see
themselves making decisions, and
steering the future of a company,
or operation.
And maybe not necessarily seeing that
support from senior leaders as well.
>> So that leads me to the question,
what do you think of is the,
where's the power dynamic right now
between older and younger workers?
It's interesting because on the one hand,
there's certainly ageism in the country,
there's no doubt that that is an issue.
On the other hand, I hear a lot
about younger workers failing,
not having the opportunity to ascend
to decision making positions.
So how do you all see the tension, or
the power dynamic playing out right
now between older and younger workers?
Manu, I'd love to hear your thoughts.
>> Sure, and thank you all so
much for having me and
great to be in conversation
with Jennifer and Laura.
And I do have to certainly
relate to the line that Laura
said at the end which is that younger
teams are a lot more prone to mistakes.
As someone that is now full
time in a dorm room project,
I can tell you that our mistakes
far outnumber our successes,
and right now we're in a hiring pinch for
older workers.
So, that's sort of the perspective
that I'm bringing.
The other perspective I'm bringing is
that, it was my first full time year of
work and I've only known
the pandemic as a workspace, and
that's actually a very
interesting dynamic.
For when you look at a lot of folks that
are especially at the older end of gen Z,
I don't even know technically
if I qualify as gen Z, but
I don't also qualify as a millennial.
So somewhere in the middle there, but
basically you have this string of
workers from the age of about,
I would say 21 to 23, that have never
actually been to the workplace.
And so, that is an interesting dynamic
that a lot of people have to contend with
when they do start opening offices.
To your direct question about what
are sort of the power dynamics and
the opportunities?
I think the opportunity is that you
have a tremendous opportunity for
social cohesion.
I mean when you see five different
age cohorts in one place,
I mean right now I'm hard pressed to
find another area of social space, or
impact where you have that much diversity
of views, viewpoints, and ages.
That means that your workplace is
essentially what Tocqueville used to
call is your voluntary political
association, because I don't know what
else is town square these days,
and so that's what you have.
That's a huge opportunity point, not just
from a political sense, but from a from
a social and melting pot sense, where
we're seeking more and more connection.
But to your point about I would say
power dynamics, especially now,
I think young people often underestimate
the power of being young in the workplace.
I mean, from my experience what I've
noticed and this might be very relevant to
me, but from folks that are now
entering the workspace.
There is a lot of opportunity that a lot
of younger people have had because of
their initiative and
drive that they've shown.
And a lot of your older power dynamics,
I don't think are as relevant in some of
your newer industries, especially when
you look at tech, venture capital,
a lot of the industries a lot
of GSB folks be going into.
Because they're are a lot
more flexible and
I think the success is less age dependent,
more experienced dependent.
Last point that I would just
say in terms of power dynamics.
The disadvantage here and the risk is that
I think you're at a unique moment in this
country's history where tying and
separating work, and political, and
social issues,
becoming increasingly more difficult.
I'm often in conversations
with a lot of industry leaders
where they have to decide whether or
not they have to issue
a statement on let's say the voting rights
bill, or various other cultural issues.
And I'm not the one that's trying to
bring in politics to the room, but
that's the decisions that are being made.
And so the dynamic that introduces is, you
have a generation of value differences at
the political level that can create
a lot of tension in the workplace.
And I think that is something that
a lot of leaders are going to have to
contend with.
>> I'm happy you brought up the kind of
tensions between the generations,
because you and I are both referenced
the broad diversity in the workplace, and
the potential benefits
associated with that.
But if we've learnt anything
over the last few years is that
diversity can also lead to
a lot of conflict, right?
And so, I'm wondering how you are managing
that conflict, and it's come up, right?
So you hear people talking about
boomers in discouraging ways, right?
And then by the same token, you hear a lot
of negative stereotypes of millennials and
Gen Zs, right?
How do you, when you bring all these
people together, how do you create
the situation so that you get the benefits
associated with that diversity?
As opposed to getting balkanization
like these fractures along these
generational lines, especially
with the differences in values, or
political opinions, and
tied to those differences.
So I'll [CROSSTALK] Laura,
you go ahead I'd love it.
[LAUGH]
>> Because I was thinking of what Monica
said, and social psychology,
probably the best supported
way to bring different kinds
of communities together,
is by creating a group where everybody's
working toward the same goal.
And I think the workplace is
an excellent place for that to happen,
because you have the same productivity
goal, the same output goal.
And bringing people together with
different perspectives when you're
working towards the same goal is
really a great way to unite people.
I see the workforce,
whether paid or unpaid,
volunteer workforce is another way
to bring generations together,
where you're coming together
because you care about something.
So, people work in a particular kind of
a discipline because it matters to them,
right?
So, there are some shared values and
you put them together, and
that's where I think you start
to see lots of common ground.
>> And if I could just add to that,
I think when you're thinking about
where diversity can often produce more
discord than sort of what you were talking
about unity towards a certain goal.
I think one of the biggest factors we've
seen in our organization for example, and
we work in different continents both at
the university and high school level, so
you both have a diversity in Gen Z itself,
but then you have cultural diversity.
And on top of that you have
layered age diversity, so
it's a diversity melting pot,
let's just say that.
And the big challenge there,
we've noticed is miscommunication and
lack of ability for people to
actually raise concerns and thoughts.
I think there's often this, especially
now with our cultural moment, workers,
regardless of what age you are,
what you believe.
Everyone's thinking about that certain
thing that's happening in the world, and
no one knows how to address it or
talk about it, and
now your company's talking about
that issue in a public light.
And the best way I think to capture
those diverse viewpoints is to make and
allow spaces in companies,
spaces in organizations for
people to have those conversations.
To have those smooth dialogues,
to be able to facilitate
intergenerational communication.
And to not shy away from the issues
that are often seen as obstacles towards
company productivity, but instead use them
as reasons for people to be comfortable,
and engaging expressing their views.
I think when you position your
company as very diverse, but
don't allow diverse opinions to percolate,
then I think there's a counterintuitive
effect that can actually hinder
the productivity of diversity.
I agree, couldn't agree more.
And that again, when we talk about
sort of what's the big story?
Is it an ageing workforce or
is it an aged diverse workforce?
And then we talked about cohort
differences, the differences may really
come about more because of ethnic,
and racial diversity, as
a function of both cohort in the country,
than it does as a function of age.
But we tend to meld those things,
to conflate them, and
so we talk about older people as being
more prejudice or bigoted or something.
But it really reflects the kind of
population which they were born into and
grew up with more than it does age,
I guess is what I'm saying.
So I think we need to be careful about
what we think of as the age problem,
and what we think of as the diversity
problem, which is real, and
one that we need to address.
>> And speaking of that, how do you, so
no matter how open we are to the age
diversity in the workplace,
there will be generational shifts, right?
How do we manage those effectively?
What is the expectation?
When should people who
are older make space for
people that are younger, is that a way?
How should we even think
about that question?
And how do you manage generational
shifts and power gracefully?
>> People tend to think
that of workforces as
zero-sum games as a fixed pot.
And that is not a good way
to think of the workforce.
The more people who work in a population,
the more jobs to get created,
and so it is a zero-sum game, and
we need to first recognize that.
Second, there appears to be
lots of just sort of natural,
pro-social investments that older
workers have for younger workers.
So there's an awful lot
of mentoring that goes
on around the water
fountain in the hallways.
With the older workers helping younger
workers advance their own careers,
and that's the kind of really nice
developmental trend that we seem to see.
UC Berkeley had a program years ago where
they were trying to get rid of the older
professors.
And so they were giving people really
sweet buyout deals to go away,
and of course two things happened.
One was the top professors just left and
got jobs at other universities and
took, [LAUGH] the sweetheart
deal too to leave.
But what happened is that the assistant
professors were struggling, and
because they didn't have older
colleagues who were saying,
you should talk to so-and-so, or
let me introduce you to so-and-so, or
there's an opportunity for
publication here.
And so
I think we need to also be aware of that.
And that's what tends to happen just
naturally when you put mixed generations
together.
>> I hear that, and I see some of
that certainly in the academy,
being a professor,
I have had that experienced.
And I've also talked to some people who
are, I'll just say let's say younger than
I am, we should kind of define what we
mean by young, because I think people.
[LAUGH] Wherever the lines
are drawn between older,
middle-aged, that young that varies,
and we're talking to, but for
now I'll just stay with younger people
I talk to, let's call it under 30.
>> Yeah.
>> And some of them are expressing,
I would say,
anger toward older generations.
And here's something that I hear, and
I'm going to push this to
you Jennifer in a second.
The older generation basically leveraged
our future to take care of themselves.
They love this this mess with the climate.
And now we're at an age
where they could buy homes,
we can't buy homes right now, we can't
afford to have families right now.
If all of this is in part
because of the way people ahead
of us manage the economy for
their own benefit at our expense.
So I'm curious Jennifer and
you because you work with,
thinking about some millennials and
maybe younger folks.
Is that something that you hear,
and how do you think about,
how that's playing out in
terms of this age dynamic?
>> Yeah, certainly, I've absolutely
heard those exact sentiments
from numerous sources that I have
spoken with over the past few months.
And there are certainly anecdotal
experiences that they can draw from there.
What they see in their
own workplace dynamic,
as well as macro level shifts in
the economy and the labor market.
I think the key is going back to Laura,
what you brought up,
there's a huge opportunity for
mentorship in the workplace.
And I think that could help
bridge some of the divides and
address some of the tensions
that if younger workers
don't see that they have a upward
path within their position or
their role at a certain company.
But being paired with someone who
has been with the employer for
a longer period of time,
they can draw from,
their years of experience to draw them up.
And I think a big issue especially for
younger workers is not seeing,
what is my contribution
to this organization,
am I just following
the footsteps of someone else?
But I think having that
dialogue in that two-way street
brainstorming, this is how
things have been done.
But also recognizing and
finding value, and
bring in new ideas could
ease some of that tension.
>> And I would just say that when you're
thinking about sort of the animosity
that younger generations have
towards older generations,
I'm going to go a little
bit against the grain and
sort of the consensus here, and
actually disagree a little bit with that.
And that what I've found is not so
much across the board sort of Gen Z and
younger millennials.
I'm suppose you're talking about,
I would say 23,
to sort of 27 and
then people from 18 to 23.
So that's sort of the age range that
I'm talking about if we're trying to be
specific, and it's not so
much a criticism of older generations
that I've seen across the board.
That certainly exists to
sort of Jennifer's point,
you hear that certainly on the coast.
And you hear that,
especially with students that
are graduating from elite universities.
But that's the key difference is,
the other big strain that I've seen is
actually more of an anti-elitism and
anti-institutional, ethic and
anti-authority ethic.
You'll see this in very basic things, like
the number one political podcast right
now in the country is not from
your establishment news outlets,
it's actually from
independent journalists.
The reason why things like Substack,
Clubhouse, enjoying these
trends are catching on is
because the younger workforce is actually
a lot more focused on criticizing trust,
and institutions, and less focused,
I think in policy issues.
And that the policy issues
might manifest in sort
of that anti-institutional critique.
But when I look at it as
anti-institutional as opposed
to they're critical of climate, or
they're critical of how the older
generation has handled x, y, z.
I think that's sort of
being the unifying trend.
And you think about it this way, anyone
that's my age or older, sort of under 30,
the four main events that have defined our
lives History are 911 the Great Recession,
the 2016 election,
the 2020 elections/the pandemic.
Those are four big
failures of institutions.
And so
that is what I've noticed sparked and
thought about how young people
are really approaching this problem and
less based on a, the older folks
are have screwed this up or that up.
Because I certainly know at least from my
angle, that this seems to be the case that
every younger generation says about
the older generation it's like hey,
that older generations.
Or is that older generations or so
then it seems like everyone screws up.
So who really is the culprit?
>> And all the old,
older generations are always talking
about those slacker young people.
I mean, they certainly were talking
about that when when I was 30s.
You were out there protesting the Vietnam
War and stuff and they're like, yeah.
[LAUGH] These kids,
they don't know anything.
And yeah,
I think there is some something to that.
There are these stereotypes that
I think are more pervasive than
actual experience with people of
different ages in the workforce
that is the stereotypes
are stronger than the behaviors.
Lots of young people work with older
workers and older workers with younger and
they don't think of them as older or
younger they think of them as Mary and
Joe.
And then you get to that and
I think that's again a way
that work can bring people together
as opposed to separate them.
But Jennifer, I think there's
really something true to this.
Old Joe is sitting in that CEO spot and
then as long if he's going to
work to lady what do I do?
What happens to the bench?
And what happens to young people
when older workers stay in jobs for
a long period of time?
What I believe is happening there is
that's real in some companies and
but it is not true for
the macro level economy.
At the macro level, as I was saying
earlier, the more older people in
the workforce, the more money there is to
spend and the more jobs that get created.
So one level,
there's no evidence for that, but
not if you work in that company
where all Joe is sitting at the top.
And so there is something real,
to that and younger worker,
younger people today are just facing
a really hard time in history.
They're not getting ahead.
The rates that their parents did,
they're not able to buy homes as young as
their parents did, or pay off debt
at the same rates or start families.
And we're seeing all of that kind
of get reflected through lots of
different milestones and
younger people are reaching those
milestones at older ages than
their prior generations did.
This is a problem I would resist
blaming it on older generations like
you did this cause I don't think any,
I'm not aware of having done that.
It's so, but it's happened and
I think all of us need to look at that and
figure out a way that all of us
can help younger people do better.
>> So what do you attribute it to?
So I mean, I think there's no, I mean,
the evidence is just clear on this, right?
The younger people are reaching
those milestones that later use.
So that's just object seems
to be objectively true.
What do you attribute that to?
I'm curious to any anyone can weigh in
here, because you what, I understand
you don't want to tribute it to
the behavior of older people, but I don't,
I'm curious what the attribution is
>> The research looks
like it's about money.
When you graduate from school and
you've got $100,000 in debt,
you don't get married.
You don't have kids.
You don't buy a house.
You don't start a retirement account.
Because you got to pay off the debt, and
that's what's happening that looks like
the financial analysis that my colleagues
have done at the longevity center.
It looks like that's what's accounting for
this.
So at the root of it, it's having
the resources to be able to move forward.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> We'll only add one more thing to this
though, this has been going on for
generations.
Jello Streeter and
some of her colleagues again at the center
did a study where they
compare different cohorts.
And what they said the ideal age was to
get married to have kids to buy a house.
And then she asked people of different
cohorts and when did you get to that age?
And for generations,
the age at which people achieve these
milestones has been getting older.
So this isn't something that
suddenly appeared in today's youth.
It's been getting older and
older gradually for decades.
The sad part is that
the ideal age at which these
milestones are achieved
hasn't changed a bit.
So young people today are saying I should
have own a home by the time I'm 30.
Most people aren't.
But the idea that's the perception and
I think that's what also contributes to
people feeling like they're being
left behind or they're not on track.
There's something wrong
with them individually.
But in fact, these trends have been
going on for a long, long time.
>> Coming in some people that should
be that to a divestment in support of
human capital in particular education,
>> Right.
>> And so I wonder how it like this
takes us kind of to politics, right,
because that's basically that's policy.
And you could argue that the people
in power politically are aging and
that might be somewhat zero sum, right?
And unlike the workforce, so
I wonder how you think about that aging
in politics should we try to do
something about the way our political
system works in terms of term limits or
something else.
To make sure that diversity we see say
example, for example in the workplace is
also reflected among the people who
are making decisions in terms of policy.
>> Before I sorry go ahead, Laura.
>> No, I was just putting thumbs up.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, no before it before I answer that
question directly, the one issue that
I've noticed that really affects
politics right now and you see this across
sort of the last couple of decades,
is not just an age issue,
but actually a brain drain.
I mean writ large, you see your smartest
people not going into public service.
They're not going to social courses.
They're not going into basic public
institutions that actually affect every
piece of your daily life.
You want your smartest McKenzie slash
whatever the case might be, and
I can say that because I'm at the GSP.
If we were in Kansas-
>> [LAUGH]
>> I would not be saying the McKenzie
consultant, but here we can say that.
You want them going to be your mayor,
to run your local city council.
You need people to be using basic
business skills that you learned and
you're not seeing that.
And I think, and this is the connection.
The reason why that exists is
because you see your role models and
politics being so old.
I think there's one this stigma that you
can only enter politics once your hair
starts growing.
And I mean, that's only reinforced by
the fact that the current, for example,
one of the Senators on the Republican
side just agreed to run for re-election.
He's 88 isn't Chuck Grassley?
I mean,
nothing against Senator Grassley with it.
That's a really old age and
you can cast your own judgment on that.
But that I mean the fact that
those are your role models and
that's the age there's
just an issue there with,
you're not going to have your
younger people going in.
The second I think issue with regards to
having older politicians in power is that
naturally change happens and
you want your leaders to be associated and
understand that change very strategically.
A core example of this is the hearings
around social media companies.
I mean, the amount of fun that Senators
and members of Congress got made of,
because they didn't know
what Facebook was is,
you can't be governing when you
don't understand the policies.
And so we can fix that,
we can educate, engage, but again,
I think there's a broader issue and
it gets to your question.
Dr. Lowery that do you want term limits?
Do you want some sort of institutional
check, I think across the board.
And again, this goes to the point
of anti institutionalism.
Anti elitism.
There's a strain and an anxiety against
people that have been empowered for
a really long time.
You're really old CEO, for example,
is I think term limits
are supported across the board.
And not just by younger people,
but also by older politicians.
One of the big fears that a lot of
political leaders have actually by folks
like, for example, Nancy Pelosi
recently said in an interview,
the reason why she's still in office
is not because she wants to be.
But because she's scared that no one
else is there to take the mantle.
So they're not going to say necessarily
that they're there because they
want to hang out.
I mean, I totally understand that
a lot of them want to go off and
do their things beyond politics.
But there's a nervousness and
anxiety that people aren't there
to ready to take up the mantle.
So you have this vicious cycle where
new talent isn't coming in older talent
distinct because of that.
And as a result,
you only have your oldest town at the top.
>> Do not be afraid.
And then you just tell me the young
people are anti institution.
Why would I want to pursue the government?
>> Well see there's a difference there.
It's not that they're anti institution in
the sense that they hate the government.
It's that there's a mistrust in
the current leadership of various
institutions.
It's not that people hate people in suits,
right?
No one, that the idea you have to control
the institutions to create change.
It's that there's a mistrust and
distrust in how those institutions have
been operating, which is different.
Because no one's trying to burn down
institutions people are just trying to
reform them,which is
a critical distinction.
>> This is where incubators and
organizations that can help
identify people to run for
elected office and
support them and help fundraiser.
And have those resources draw from I mean,
making the decision to run for office.
It requires having a job that gives
you that flexibility to campaign,
and if you win to take on
those responsibilities.
And maintain a paid job with a wage for
your lifestyle.
For a lot of public servant jobs
the pay is just not there for
it to be this aspirational career
you don't go into it for the money.
But it all comes back to money.
If people don't have a lot of
the financial resources to be able
to support themselves as they continue
on this additional goal of theirs.
They're not going to feel that there
is space for them to give it a shot.
>> I mean for perspective, the salary
of a senate page or Senate clerk right
who's just working on the hill
first year out, is I think $32,000.
No bonuses and
the most basic insurance benefits.
They're very smart, intelligent people.
But why would you in your right
mind choose to go live in DC and
be paid $32,000 it's
just not going to cut it.
And so I think Jennifer is absolutely
right that you have to think about pay.
There's a little bit of a fear
of opening up incubation
competitions on political things and
the fear around that.
Is whether or not it just depends on
who's running those competitions.
And what are the standards and
what are the rules.
But that's not a conversation you
heard there, but on the same page.
>> We live in a gerontocracy,
and it is a problem.
We are being governed by
a very old white male.
Elite group of people, and
although there have been some changes in
that there haven't been
enough changes in it.
What I would add to the need for
younger people representing
populations in DC.
Would be some kind of policies,
that would review any
kind of new legislation to
evaluate how it will affect
different generations.
A colleague of mine at Harvard, Lisa
Beckman has been advocating for this so
that we would have some
kind of a committee.
Let's say you're going to increase
payments in social security.
And what you would have to do before
you did that you could do it and
you could advocate for whatever.
But you have to say,
this is what it's going to do for
people who are 10 years younger,
20 years younger, 30 years younger.
And so that we'd be able to see that.
You can imagine the same
kind of things for climate and
all sort of different kind of
policies that could be advocated.
I think we have reached this point
with an age-diverse society.
Where we need to think deeply about
how the changes that we advocate for
are going to affect not just the current
generation but future generations.
>> So one more question for each of you.
What do you think is
the most pressing issue?
What would you want to leave people
thinking about with respect to age and
re imagining work, what we need to
do to have a vibrant workforce?
And society going forward the most
pressing issue nearby Laura Christensen.
>> Sure.
It's a lack of imagination.
We need to ask the question,
what are the opportunities here and
instead we have this white
knuckle approach of bracing for
the fall and my gosh, we're going to
get the old people and workforce.
And what's going to happen to the young
people and we're just getting.
And instead we need to just kind of
take a step back for a minute and say,
here's the workforce today because
people are going to work longer.
And we're going to have old
people we know that now.
And to start to say,
how do we exploit that?
[LAUGH].
Optimally in ways that improve life for
everybody.
That's the question and
I think we spend a lot of time
worrying about the problems and
what we really should be doing is thinking
about solutions and new opportunities.
>> Great, Jennifer, what do you think?
>> Yeah, I think related, I mean.
The way that so many people have been
working in the last 18 months is
completely different from
what they have known before.
It has presented such opportunity
in the way of flexible work.
That I think a main challenge up to,
the people in charge is understanding
how workplaces can be flexible and
accommodate the needs of their
employees at various life stages.
Right now I'm doing some reporting
on women being forced out
of the labor force due
to ongoing childcare.
And dependent care needs.
But employers have shown that
they have the resources if
they want to invest in women.
And invest in underrepresented employees,
they have the levers to pull on and
that varies so much throughout.
Life stages into the aging workforce and
I think there's so
much opportunity there we
can really be pushing more.
>> Mani, what do you think?
>> Yeah, I think, I'll just give
an example of our organization.
So, we actually faced the totally opposite
problem which is that we just have too
many young people.
And and the entire dynamic
is focused on young people.
Now that's for good reason because
we're student led movement and
we're trying to improve the way that
young people are having conversations.
So you want young people to help them.
But actually the problem that we're
running into now is that there's both
a lack of experience.
And also, we want smarter people than us
in our leadership teams that we can be
making better decisions.
And so this goes to Laura's point,
which is.
That's our situation.
So how do we fix it?
It wasn't thinking about older young
people it was who can fill this skill gap
which is we need experience.
We need smarter folks and we people
that have made mistakes in the past so
they can get better.
And they can teach us so
we have to make those mistakes.
Who fits the bill people
lots of experience?
Got lots of experience older people.
And so I think rather than looking at the
situation as sort of Laura's describing
Jennifer there was just saying in relation
to the workplace is structured is it's not
necessarily a problem.
It's just a situation.
The situation is that we've got huge age
gaps and you got a lot of old people,
a lot of young people.
It's a situation is not a problem yet.
The problem becomes when we look at it
as something that's insurmountable but
actually it's filling a huge value gap.
I mean right now your younger folks
are bringing a very diverse and
interesting perspective.
They've gotten you skills.
They've got new technologies and
you can harness the older wisdom
to not be obstacles to that.
But to be jet fuel to propel that
forward without making the mistakes that
they've made in the past.
>> Great Well, all of you are very
optimistic about the future.
I really appreciate that.
[LAUGH].
And hope that the way things develop,
support that optimism.
But I really appreciate
the time that you brought so
I can talk with you all tonight.
So thanks so much for taking the time.
>> Thanks Fred.
>> Thank you for moderating.
>> Like wise thank you.
>> Thanks.
So next week I'll be joined by
Rachel Carlson of Gilt Education.
And David Osborne, the author reinventing
American schools to discuss education.
So I hope that you all join that.
Thanks so much.
Have a good night.